[Music]
welcome valued listeners and Watchers
today we're honored to introduce this
remarkable guest an extraordinary
extraordinary thinker who transcends
conventional boundaries Daniel
schmotenberger what are the underlying
causes that everything from nuclear war
to environmental degradation to animal
rights issues to class issues what do
these things have in common as a
multi-disciplinary aficionado Daniel's
expertise spans complex systems theory
evolutionary Dynamics and existential
risk topics that challenge the Forefront
of academic exploration seamlessly
melding different fields such as
philosophy neuroscience and
sustainability he offers a comprehensive
understanding of our world's most
pressing challenges
really the thing we have to shift is the
economy because perverse economic
incentive is under the whole thing
there's no way that as long as you have
a for-profit military-industrial complex
as the largest block of the global
economy that you could ever have peace
there's an anti-incentive on it as long
as there's so much money to be made with
mining Etc like we have to fix the
nature of economic incentives in 2018
Daniel co-founded the consilience
project a groundbreaking initiative that
aims to Foster societal-wide
transformation via the synthesis of
disparate domains promoting
collaboration Innovation as well as
something we used to call wisdom today's
conversation delves into AI
Consciousness and morality aligning with
the themes of the toe podcast it May
challenge your beliefs it'll present
alternative perspectives to the AI risk
scenarios by also outlining the positive
cases which are often overlooked
ultimately Daniel offers a fresh outlook
on the interconnectedness of reality say
let's get the decentralized collective
intelligence of the world having the
best best Frameworks for understanding
the most fundamental problems as the
center of the Innovative focus of the
creativity of the world so Utah watches
you my name is Kurt J mungle prepare for
a captivating Journey as we explore the
Peerless enthralling world of Daniel
schmotenberger enjoy
[Music]
foreign
I do not know with what weapons World
War III will be fought but World War 4
will be fought with sticks and stones
all right Daniel
what have you been up to in the past few
years
few years
trying to
understand
the
unfolding Global situation
and the
trajectories towards existential and
Global catastrophic risk in particular
the
solutions to those that involve control
mechanisms that create trajectories
towards dystopias
and the consideration of what a world
that is neither in the attractor Basin
of catastrophe or dystopia looks like a
kind of third attractor
uh what we did take to have a
civilization that could Steward the
power of exponential technology
much better than we have stewarded all
of our previous technological power
what would that mean in terms of culture
and in terms of political economies and
governance and things like that
so thinking about those things and uh
acting on specific cases of near-term
catastrophic risks that we're hoping to
ameliorate and helping with various
projects on
how to transition institutions to be
more intelligent and things like that
what are some of these near-term
catastrophic risks
well as of today
we are
in a war that has moved the atomic clock
closer to midnight than it has ever been
and that's a pretty obvious one
and
if
if we were to write a book about the
Folly of the history of human hubris
um
we would get very concerned about where
we are confident about where we're right
where we might actually be wrong and the
consequences of it and as we're dealing
with nukes and Ai and things like that
we could easily have the last chapter in
that book if we are not uh more careful
about confident wrong ideas
uh so what is a
uh what are all the assumptions in the
way we're navigating that particular
conflict uh that might not be right
what are the ways we are modeling the
various sides and what would an end
state that is viable for the world and
the just at minimum doesn't go to a
global catastrophic risk that's an
example
if we look at the domain of synthetic
biology as an exponential is a different
kind of advanced technology exponential
Tech
and we look at
that the cost of things like Gene
sequencing and then the ability to
synthesize genomes Gene printing are
dropping faster than Moore's law in cost
well open science means that the most
virulent viruses possible studied in
um
contexts that have ethical review boards
getting open published then that's a
situation where that knowledge combined
with near-term decentralized Gene
printers is
decentralized catastrophe weapons on
purpose or even accidentally
there are heaps of examples in the
environmental space if we look at our
planetary boundaries climate change the
one people have the most awareness of
publicly but if you look at the other
planetary boundaries like
mining pollution or chemical pollution
or nitrogen dead zones and oceans or
biodiversity loss or species Extinction
we've already passed certain tipping
points the question is uh how runaway
are those effects
there was an article published a few
months ago on pfos and pfas the
fluorinated surfactants forever
chemicals as they're popularly called
that found higher than EPA allowable
standards of them in rainwater all
around the world including in snowfall
in Antarctica because actually evaporate
and we're not slowing down on the
production of those in their endocrine
disruptors and carcinogens and and that
doesn't just affect humans but affects
things like
the entirety of ecology and soil
microorganisms is kind of a humongous
effect so those are all examples and I
would say right now I know the topic of
our conversation today is AI
uh AI is both a novel example of a
possible catastrophic risk through
certain types of utilization
it is also an accelerant to every
category of catastrophic risk
potentially so that one has a lot of
attention at the moment so that makes AI
different than the rest that you've
mentioned
definitely
and are you focused primarily on
avoiding disaster or moving towards
something that's much more Heavenly or
positive like a Shangri-La
so
we have an assessment
called The Meta crisis the it's a more
popular term out there right now the
poly crisis we've been calling this The
Meta crisis since before coming across
that term polycrisis is the idea that
the global catastrophic risk that we all
need to focus on and coordinate on is
not just climate change and it's not
just wealth inequality and it's not just
um kind of the breakdown of pax
Americana and the possibility of war or
these species Extinction issues but it's
lots of things there's lots of different
Global catastrophic risks and that they
interact with each other and they're
complicated and there can even be
Cascades between them right we don't
have to have climate change
produce total venusification of the
earth to produce a global catastrophic
risk it just has to increase the
likelihood of extreme weather events in
an area
and we've already seen that happening
statistics on that seem quite clear and
it's not just total climate change
deforestation affecting local
transpiration and heat in an area can
have an effect on
um and total amount of pavement laid and
whatever can have an effect on extreme
weather events
but Extreme weather events I mean we saw
what happened to Australia a couple
years ago when a significant percentage
of a whole continent burned in a way
that we don't have near-term historical
precedent for
we saw the way that droughts affected
the migration that led to the whole
Syrian conflict that got very close to a
much larger scale conflict
the Australia
situation happened to hit a low
population density area but there are
plenty of high population density areas
that are getting very near the
temperatures that create total crop
failures whether we're talking about
India Pakistan Bangladesh Nigeria Iran
and so if you have massive human
migration the UN currently predicts
hundreds of millions of climate mediated
migrants in the next decade and a half
um
then it's pretty easy under those
situations to have resource Wars and
those can hit existing political fault
lines and then technological
amplification and so in the past we
obviously have a lot less people right
we only had half a billion people for
the entirety of the history of the world
to the Industrial Revolution
and then with the Green Revolution and
nitrogen fertilizer and oil and like
that we went from half a billion people
to
8 billion people
overnight in historical timelines
and we went from those people mostly
living on local subsistence to almost
all living on dependent upon
very complicated Supply chains now that
are six continent mediated Supply chains
so that means that
uh there's radically more fragility in
the life support systems so that local
catastrophes can turn to breakdowns of
Supply chains economic effects Etc that
affect people very widely so poly crisis
kind of looking at all that meta crisis
ads
looking at the underlying drivers of all
of them why do we have all of these
issues
and what would it take to solve them not
just on a point by Point basis but to
solve the underlying basis so we can see
that
all of these have to do with
coordination failures we can see that
underneath all of them there are things
like perverse economic interests if the
cost of the environmental pollution to
clean it up was something where in the
process of the corporation selling the
pfos for as a surfactant for
waterproofing clothes or whatever it
also had to pay for the cost to clean up
its effect in the environment or the oil
cost had to clean up the effect on the
environment so you didn't have the
perverse incentive to externalize costs
onto Nature's balance sheet which nobody
enforces
obviously we don't know none of those
environmental issues right that would be
a totally different situation so can we
address perverse incentive writ large
that would change require fundamental
changes what we think of as economy and
how we enact that's a political economy
so we think about those things so I
would say with the meta crisis
assessment we'd say that we're in a very
novel position with regard to
catastrophic risk Global catastrophic
risk because until World War II
there was no technology big enough to
cause a global catastrophic risk as a
result of dumb human choices or human
failure quickly and then with the bomb
there was it was the beginning and
that's
a moment ago in evolutionary time right
and if we reverse back a little bit
before the bomb until the Industrial
Revolution we couldn't we didn't have
any technology that could have caused
Global catastrophic risk even
cumulatively
the industrial technology extracting
stuff from nature and turning it into
human stuff for a little while before
turning into pollution and trash where
we're extracting stuff from nature in
ways that destroy the environment faster
than nature can replenish and then
turning it into trash and pollution
faster than it can be processed and
doing exponentially more of that because
it's coupled to a economy that requires
exponential growth to keep up with
interest
that creates an existential risk it
creates a catastrophic risk within about
a few centuries of cumulative effects
and we're basically at that few century
point
and so that's very new are all of our
historical systems for that in our
historical systems for thinking about
governance in the world didn't have to
deal with those effects we could just
kind of think about the world as
inexhaustible
um
and then of course when we got the bomb
we're like all right this is the first
technology that rather than racing to
implement we have to ensure that no one
ever uses in all previous Technologies
there was a race to implement it it was
a very different situation
but since that time a lot more
catastrophic technologies have emerged
catastrophic Technologies in terms of
applications of AI and synthetic biology
and cyber and various things that are
way easier to build the nukes and way
harder to control and when you have many
actors that have access to many
different types of catastrophic
technology that can't be monitored you
don't get mutually assured destruction
and those types of safeties
so we'd say that we're in a situation
where the catastrophic wrist landscape
is a novel nothing in history has been
anything like it
and the current trajectory doesn't look
awesome for making it through what it
would take to make it through actually
requires change to those underlying
coordinate coordination structures of
humanity very deeply
so I don't see a model where we do make
it through those that doesn't also
become a whole lot more awesome
and that's what we say the only other
example is to control for catastrophes
you can try to put very strong control
Provisions Okay so
now unlike in the past people could or
pretty soon have Gene drives where they
could build pandemic weapons in their
basement or drone weapons where they
could take out infrastructure targets or
now ai weapons even easier
we can't let that happen so we need
ubiquitous surveillance to know what
everybody's doing in their basement
because if we don't then the world is
unacceptably fragile so we can see
catastrophes or dystopias right because
most versions of ubiquitous surveillance
are pretty terrible
and so if you can control decentralized
action if you don't control
decentralized action the current
decentralized action is moving towards
planetary boundaries and conflict and
Etc
if you control it then who what are the
checks and balances on that control
sorry what do you mean control
decentralized actions
so when we look at what is what it
causes catastrophe so when we're talking
about environmental issues there's not
one group that is taking all the fish
out of the ocean or causing species
Extinction or doing all the pollution is
a decentralized incentive that lots of
companies share
to do those things so nobody's
intentionally trying to remove all the
fish from the ocean they're trying to
meet an economic incentive that they
have that's associated with fishing but
the cumulative effect of that is
overfishing the ocean right
so if you try to if there's a
decentralized set of activity where the
lack of coordination of everybody doing
that everybody pursuing their own
near-term Optimum creates the shitty
term Global minimum for everybody right
a long-term bad outcome for everybody if
you try to create some centralized
control against that that's a lot of
centralized power
and where the checks and balances on
that power otherwise how do you create
decentralized coordination
and similarly if you're looking at
things like
in an age where terrorism can get
exponential Technologies
and you don't want exponentially
empowered terrorism with catastrophe
weapons for everyone
to be able to see what's being developed
ahead of time does that look like a
degree of surveillance that nobody wants
to be able to control those things not
happening right that's what I mean so if
you how to prevent the catastrophes if
the catastrophes are currently the
result of the human motivational
landscape in a decentralized way
if the solution is a centralized method
powerful enough to do it where the
checks and balances on that power so a
future that is neither
cascading catastrophes nor control
dystopias is the one that we're
interested in and so yes I would say the
whole focus is that this is now ai comes
back into the topic because a lot of
people see possibilities for a very
protopian future with AI where it can
help solve coordination issues and solve
lots of resource allocation issues it
also and it can it can also make lots of
things the catastrophe is worse and
dystopia's worse it's actually kind of
unique in being able to make both of
those things more powerful
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy